foreign
[Music]
I just came across this famous quote by
Albert Einstein the important thing is
to not stop questioning yes and that's
exactly what different scientists did
one Discovery led to another Discovery
and do you know what that resulted in
the discovery of subatomic particles
in 1897 JJ Thompson discovered
negatively charged particles or
electrons but the confusion was how can
atoms be neutral if they consist of
negatively charged particles
this confusion was cleared by the
results of some experiments performed by
a German physicist Eugene Goldstein
March before JJ Thompson in 1886 Eugene
Goldstein performed an experiment using
a discharge tube he divided the tube
into two Chambers with a perforated
metal plate this plate acted as a
cathode an anode plate was placed at the
other end of the first chamber
amount of residual gas was present
between the anode and the cathode when
he applied voltage cathode rays began to
move from the cathode to the anode and
when they struck a gas molecule on their
way it emitted charged particles these
particles moved towards the cathode
passing through the holes in the cathode
plate and produced a beam at the back of
the cathode since they moved from anode
to cathode they were called anode Rays
Goldstein later tested these Rays he
observed that in the presence of an
electric field the Rays changed their
path they deflected away from the
positive charge this indicated that the
particles were positively charged hence
he concluded the anode rays were
composed of positively charged particles
however he didn't fully understand what
he had discovered
it was many years later in 1920 that
Rutherford performed different
experiments and concluded that these
positively charged particles were
protons
protons are positively charged subatomic
particles carrying a unit positive
charge and mass equal to the mass of a
hydrogen atom
many such discoveries were made to give
the final structure of an atom just like
these scientists we should also be
curious and keep asking questions about
things until next time